[inaudible]
Spain is known as who?
Your Iglesias,
this country,
the land of the Flamenco and high
unemployment rates.
Even now when all of Europe is emerging
from the crisis,
this country maintains a higher
unemployment rate than Iraq or Albania.
In other words,
Spain isn't exactly a role model as far
as economics is consent.
However,
there's a region that doesn't fit at all
in this category.
Yes,
Divya,
we all talking about the basket country,
also known as a use Katie along with
Nevada.
These are two of the richest stands,
most prosperous regions in the entire of
Spain,
both of the Basque country and the Vara
usually at the top of every indicator,
far above,
by the way,
Catalonia.
In other words,
we could say that these two regions are
something like a small Germany within
Spain with an entirely different
political systems to the rest of the
country as a business sector,
more typical of northern Europe than
southern Europe.
Moreover,
this area has it's own language.
This is called a will scatter.
Unlike castle on a hill scatter sounds
nothing like casper and,
but that is not all like a catalonia.
The Basque country.
Also has an important separatist
movement.
In fact,
10 years before castle and politicians
began to demand independence,
the basket governments had also tried to
become a sovereign state.
This was known as the [inaudible] j
plan.
See the then president of the basket
country borders is officially called to
the basket of [inaudible] Juan Jose
about [inaudible] tried to divorce from
Spain and they went pretty badly.
Most of that is something we are going
to address in a whole of the video.
Sorry,
let's get onto today's question and
that's why is the best country and
Novari richer than the rest of Spain?
Why do we say that they have a different
political systems the rest of the
country?
Well,
we are going to answer all of those
questions today,
but before we do,
let's dive into the history.
We'll heritage both regions.
The Basque Country End Avara have a
special status called the Basque
economic agreements.
Any people think that this special
status came from the Middle Ages,
but the truth is that it did see in the
year 1200 the ancient kingdom of Novari
what are now known as the are larva is
Kaia and geepers Korea provinces and
Nevara itself joins the castiel crown as
a condition for this union.
The castilian king had to recognize
these circles and never reason Queiroz
or laws.
That is to say that this kingdom would
maintain an independent government with
its own laws,
its own courts,
and did sent taxes.
For example,
no Novaris citizen could be forced to do
military service.
These novaris laws remained practically
unchanged for centuries,
but don't think that this is an anomaly.
Every feudal law absolutest political
system,
be it in Spain,
France or the United Kingdom was full of
regions with special rights and special
laws.
However,
things changed in the 19th century.
At that time,
Spain was consolidated as a modern state
and then decided to innovate the model
of Napoleon's France.
That is a centrist
model.
Well.
That means that almost every law would
be dictated from the capsule and would
apply equally throughout the territory.
As you can imagine,
this did not please the Novari's and the
Basque citizens.
Suddenly that's paying more taxes and do
compulsory military service.
Not a great combination.
There's explains why during the 19th
century,
Spain had not one,
not two,
but three civil wars.
These were the so called car list was
where the old regime supporters mainly
basques and Novaris fought against the
Spanish army.
Then in 1876 when these novaris basket
trips where if he did the laws
abolished,
suddenly these four provinces have to
follow the laws that came from the dread
and in addition,
they have to pay a percentage of their
taxes to the central states and Roseanne
Madrid's allowed them to retain a
special fiscal status.
And this concession is what we call the
Basque agreement,
which as you can see,
wasn't born in the middle ages,
but it was approved in exchange for
abolishing of the laws.
But it doesn't end there.
Decades later in 1939 Franco's
dictatorship eliminated this economic
agreement,
but only in the two provinces that
didn't support him.
We boost Koa and Vizcaya.
No,
as you can already see from all of this
is around the torture of story with wars
and demands from both sides,
both provinces,
which lost their special fiscal
conditions where especially hers,
and this can be seen today where a huge
percentage of Bisco lions and Quepos
Koans wants independence from Spain and
all.
This explains why in the 1970s the new
democratic Spanish constitutions writers
it to compensate bask and Navarro the
Basque agreements resends but this time
in a modernized version,
the Basque quota,
this is one of the most confusing issues
in Spanish politics.
See,
if a citizen lives in Malaga Raw,
valid,
the lid,
he or she pays most of their taxes
directly to the central governments.
Of course,
there are some special taxes that
depends on the city or the autonomous
community.
That's the vast majority goes to the
National Treasury afterwards,
the state distributes this money among
the different autonomous governments as
they see fit.
Yes,
these are the so called autonomic
transfers.
And of course some regions tend to
benefits from these transverse and
others are harmed.
In theory,
and this is quite debatable,
the richer regions help the poorer
regions.
However,
both Navarro ans the Basque country have
a different system.
In this case,
the provincial governments collect
almost all of the taxes.
And notice it that I said provincial.
This means that if a citizen lives,
for example,
in Bilbao,
they do not pay taxes to the Basque
government,
but to the Vizcaya provincial council,
and this provincial governments has the
autonomy to do things like this.
This KAIA will change taxes on company
profits to increase competitiveness.
So maybe you remember in another video
we told you why Switzerland is so rich.
Now,
one of the reasons for this is that in
Switzerland,
each cans on it can compete with each
other by offering better fiscal
conditions.
Well,
something similar is happening in the
basket and the Var provinces.
And that explains why it taxation in
these regions is a little lower than it
is in the rest of Spain.
Nope.
You may be wondering,
do these provincial councils pay nothing
to the Spanish state?
Well,
no,
there's none of that.
So that's where the so called basket
quarter comes into play.
The Basque quota is the percentage these
regions pay to the central government in
exchange for the common services they
enjoy for belonging.
Thanks.
Sample the army,
embassies and roads.
All these are paid by Madrid,
but the basques can also enjoy them.
They therefore I have to pay part of the
cost.
And not only that,
if for example,
Spain decided to increase the defense
budget,
the basket quarter would also grow
proportionally.
As you can imagine,
all of this is the irascible.
The truth isn't the basket quota is the
result of political negotiations.
That's a different story for a different
day.
The truth is those,
unlike all the other autonomous
communities,
the Basque country and Nevara know
exactly how much money they pay for the
common cause and how much remains,
and in most cases,
this is a fantastic advantage.
But just wait a moment because this
doesn't end.
Yeah.
In principal,
it might seem that the economic
agreements is a fair system.
Everything in the negotiation is black
and white,
but the truth is that the system is far
from perfect.
Do you remember when I said that the
central state distributes the money that
it collects among the different
autonomous communities?
While the truth is that both Nevara ans
the Basque country belong to this
distribution and it's being such rich
regions,
it would be logical to think that they
would contribute more than they receive.
Well,
that is totally not happening.
Basque
country receives twice as many resources
per capita as Madrid,
Catalonia,
or Andalusia and say,
now you maybe asking yourself this and
that as well.
How is this possible?
The reason why it's purely political,
as I was saying,
basket nationalism is as important as
Kassala national,
isn't it?
That means there's these autonomous
communities have their own political
parties,
parties such as the Basque Nationalist
Party,
which holds its communities,
governments and has a strong
representation and the national
parliaments,
well,
every year the central government has to
approve national budgets in parliaments
for that,
they need an absolute majority and
majority that's in most cases requires
support from these parties.
However,
this isn't the only reason for the
Basque country's prosperity.
Not at all.
In fact,
there's much more at play here and look
into it right now.
Germany and Spain,
have you heard of a company called
Audley?
Well,
if you have a gas stove,
you might own some of their products.
It's the world leader in manufacturing
systems for preventing accidents and gas
leaks and their headquarters are in
order Zia a town in the gift this Koa
province.
The same goes for j m a if you have an
armored door in your house,
it's highly likely that both the lock
and the keys have been manufactured by
this company,
which is located in drag on.
This is a small Basque town.
These are the so called hidden leaders.
They are small,
hyper specialized companies that have
become benchmarks in their niche and
which have devastated the international
markets.
In a previous video we told you,
you have Germany o's part of its wealth
to Middle Astons.
Well,
the Basque economic model is very
similar.
Moreover,
if you have the opportunity to travel by
road through IES Katie,
you'll see factories disbursed
throughout its landscape.
In fact,
it's population is much more scattered
than anywhere else in Spain.
Of course,
there are large cities,
but most people live in urban centers
have less than 40,000 inhabitants.
These municipalities,
business hubs then employ locals in the
Basque country.
Economic activity isn't only
concentrated in large cities,
and I,
you may ask yourself,
well,
why does [inaudible] have such a
homogenous business network for this?
We resent to the same principle at
knots,
decentralization by having four
different treasuries with autonomy to
collects taxes and make investments.
There's a higher tax competition than in
any other parts of Spain.
This means that public investments arms
concentrated in a specific place,
but are distributed evenly.
Investing in startups will have a 30%
deduction in GIB boosie core.
In other words,
it's true,
both the basques ans the Novari is have
a huge advantage because they receive
money from the central states,
but that money has been invested much
more efficiently than in any other
region.
In fact,
isn't it a coincidence that these two
communities are the least indebted in
all of Spain?
And that's in addition,
they have hardly any of the corruption
cases that have poisoned the rest of the
car
tree.
So now the question is,
do you think some elements of the basket
Novari's models could be rescued and
replicated in other countries?
Do you think it would be possible to
apply the Basque agreements to other
regions?
Well,
let us know in the comments section
below.
Also,
as always,
thank you for,
and please do leave a like,
and do you subscribe?
We have brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday.
Also.
Let me thank our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
the one on mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.